centrales energéticas bajo ataque al
norte de kiev se vio humo sobre una
instalación según Ucrania Este martes al
menos tres infraestructuras fueron
bombardeadas Aún se desconoce el número
de víctimas la ciudad de dni pero al sur
del país dos misiles cayeron en una
instalación energética entonces apunta a
una campaña deliberada del kremlin para
destruir instalaciones de Electricidad y
agua antes de la llegada del Invierno
mientras objetivos civiles fueron
atacados en nikolaive al sur de Ucrania
despertamos a la 1:45 de la madrugada
por una explosión muy fuerte es
imposible describirlo había mucho polvo
estábamos en el sótano salimos a rastras
por las aberturas del suelo nuestro
vecino murió por desgracia él estaba un
poco más cerca del lugar de la explosión
mientras que nosotros estábamos un poco
más lejos
el impacto fue en una antigua edificio
Residencial según el presidente
ucraniano quien compartió en Twitter las
imágenes del ataque los ocupantes siguen
aterrorizando a los civiles en nicolae
el enemigo destruyó un edificio
Residencial con misiles c-300 una
persona murió
por su parte Moscú niega estar atacando
civiles y dice no tener información
acerca del uso de los drones kamikaze de
fabricación iraní con los que habrían
atacado objetivos ucranianos